PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today I'd like to talk to you
about state machines.
State machines are an incredibly
important concept,
both in 6.01, and in the general
sense when you're
going to be doing things like
control theory or artificial
intelligence.
Any further work you do in terms
of computability theory,
state machines are
really important.
So I'm going to review what
we've done so far and talk
about why we now need state
machines to add additional
complexity to the kinds of
models that we're going to
build, and then talk a little
bit about how state machines
are represented in different
domains, and then also talk
about how we're going
to use state
machines in the 6.01 software.
First of all, let's review what
we've learned so far.
We've talked, so far, about
functional, imperative and
object-oriented programming
paradigms.
In functional programming,
everything is a function.
And in imperative programming,
we're allowed to use
functions, but they're also
allowed to have side effects.
And in object-oriented
programming,
everything is an object.
We can actually use the first
two to implement the last one,
and use the first one plus
an idea of maintaining
assignments to variables,
that sort of thing, to
implement this one.
So you can trace the progression
of different kinds
of computer science language
along this paradigm.
But the one thing that none of
these languages on their own
allows us to do is keep a notion
of internal state.
And what I mean by that is that
if we have a system that
we want to model in terms of
the passage of time or keep
track of the evolution of that
system or keep track of some
of the data that has accumulated
over time in that
system, then we certainly can't
do it with functional
programming.
Functional programming takes
one input, generates one
output, and you could generate
a list of codes that took in
every possible situation and
then generated the logical
output, but that would
be a lot of code.
Same thing for imperative and
object-oriented programming.
They alone do not address
everything that we want to
address, which is the ability to
look at everything that has
happened as a consequence of the
passage of time and all of
the data that we've looked at
as a consequence of the
passage of time, synthesize it
in some way, and then generate
whatever was supposed to come
out of that situation.
That is the notion of
internal state.
State machines have been
around for a while.
You might see them refer to as
discrete finite automata.
There are also such things as
continuous state machines, but
we're not going to talk about
those in this course so much.
So we're only talking about
discrete state machines.
And when you see them referred
to as state machines or
discrete finite automata in
literature, especially
mathematics, you'll be looking
for this five set of things.
One is a set of the possible
states you could be in, given
a particular state machine.
One is the set of inputs you
could possibly encounter while
in that state machine.
One is the set of outputs that
that state machine could
possibly generate.
One is a transition function
that looks at pairs of these
values and tells you, based on
which state you're currently
in, what state you will end up
in as a consequence of the
current input, and then also
specify what the output will
be as a consequence of
that transition.
And finally, it'll tell you
where you start out.
That's a lot to absorb.
I'm going to show you a state
transition diagram, which many
of you have probably seen
before, and map these values
to this state transition diagram
in hopes of making
this a little bit
more concrete.
Hopefully at this point, all
of you who have interacted
with an MBTA turnstile.
This is a thing that opens and
closes, and you stick your
RFID card on it, and then
Richard Stallman yells at you
and possibly hands you more
Charlie tickets or
something like that.
It has four states.
One of them is that this
turnstile could be closed, and
it's waiting for people to
interact with it in some way.
It could be open, and I
anthropomorphize the turnstile
as being happy as a consequence
of you putting
money in it.
It could be open and quiet as a
consequence of usually some
sort of other previous
interaction
with another person.
Or it could be open and angry
as a consequence of people
interacting with it when
they should not.
The vertices in this directed
graph are my set of states.
So when you see something like
this, and you're asked to map
it to the mathematical
construct, just grab the names
and say this is my
set of states.
Let's say I start
off in closed.
And actually, it occurs to me
that the other thing that
should be specified
is a start state.
And it's not here.
So let's say the turnstile
starts off as closed.
Usually this is an arrow coming
out of nowhere that
directs into one
of the states.
Sometimes it will be explicitly
indicated by saying
start state, but typically
you'll just see
an arrow from nowhere.
At this point, I don't have
any inputs or outputs.
If I put money in the turnstile,
it constitutes
input to my system.
It's going to end up in my
set of inputs for math.
My transition function looks at
the state I'm in and looks
at the current input and
generates the output and the
next state.
So all of these arrows, in
addition to whatever
information is contained in
the receiving vertex,
specifies my transition
function.
Any transition that's not
specified is not considered in
the function.
This was not part of our
original drawing.
So if I was fed open angry,
there would be no way to get
to open happy.
Likewise, if I was in open angry
and fed money for this
simple system, we're going to
say nothing would happen.
I think at this point it's
become clear how to transform
a state transition diagram
into the mathematical
constructs.
It's good to have the
mathematical constructs,
because they end up being used
in software, which I'll talk
about in a second.
But the first thing I'm going to
do is just walk around the
state transition diagram and
indicate what would be inputs,
what would be outputs,
that sort of thing.
So let's say I walk up to the
turnstile and somebody else
interacts with the turnstile
by exiting.
In this case, exit is the input,
none is the output, the
turnstile doesn't make
any noise, and the
turnstile is open.
If at that point I interact
with the turnstile by
entering, it's going to make
noise, which is the output.
And then the new state is going
to be that the turnstile
is open and angry.
At that point, you and
I know that the
turnstile is going to close.
So this edge indicates that the
only available input at
that point is to do nothing.
Or independent of anything else,
it's going to squawk
again and close.
One more time, here
are the states.
Inputs are the first
of these two pairs.
Outputs, as a consequence of the
transition, is the second
of these two pairs.
And the transition function is
represented by the directed
edge and the new state.
Once you have all those sets
figured out, you can start
talking about how to implement
state machines and software.
We've actually abstracted
this away from you.
You don't have to
deal with it.
But as a consequence, you should
know how to interact
with the 6.01 library.
Let's look at an example of
the state machine class.
I want to build an accumulator,
which at every
time step we'll look at the
input, add it to every other
example of input and output, and
output the new value and
retain it as the new state.
The first thing I need to do is
initialize the accumulator
with a value.
This is our start state, which
is the same as our start state
from the MBTA turnstile, and
also the same as our start
state from the mathematical
construct.
I also want something called
getNext Values which is the
functional equivalent
of the transitions.
Here's our self again from
object oriented programming --
but we don't care about that.
We're going to look at
the current state
and the current input.
Some getNext Values we'll do
some internal data munging,
possibly multiplication by two
or comparing to the previous
input and then having
some conditionals,
that sort of thing.
But there'll be some sort of
very simple function under
getNext Values at least for
the first couple of weeks.
And then we will return
the new state and
the output into tuple.
In this case, the new state
is going to be the linear
combination of the current state
and the current input.
And the output is going to be
the linear combination of the
current state and the
current input.
If I were to draw this
accumulator as a state
transition diagram,
I would do this.
My start state is the
initial value.
If I pass in a new input--
we'll call it input 0 --
both my output and the new
state are going to be the
linear combination of
these two values.
If I made another transition, I
would take whatever my next
input was and add it to the
current state value and return
it out as the output, and
so on and so forth.
I encourage you try this in
Python, or in IDLE and munge
around with it and see what
you can get it to do.
You might have to type add
lib6.01 in order to get the
state machine class, or
initialize using lib6.01 in
order to get the state
machine class.
But otherwise, those should be
enough to get you started with
an introduction to
state machines.
If you're having trouble, I
highly recommend going through
all the examples in
the readings.
They're pretty comprehensive,
and it also includes the
accumulator.
That's all for now.
Next time we'll talk about
linear time varying systems.